uh Marjorie Taylor green radical
republican congresswoman said yesterday
that Tucker Carlson's filing uh firing
by Fox News was illegal now she doesn't
use the word illegal but it's really
important to understand when these
people on the right say that was a
violation of the First Amendment
they are saying that it is against the
law what took place we're going to look
at a video clip of Marjorie Taylor green
explaining I guess her perspective if
you can call it that what is really
important to understand is that when she
says Tucker's First Amendment rights
were violated by Fox News she's saying
it was an illegal firing these are the
people who hold as one of their most
important stated values low business
regulation let businesses do what they
want to do Law and Order
um we we need to unburden businesses
from government limitations they should
be allowed to do what is best and most
profitable for them and here she says a
firing by a private company
was unconstitutional and therefore
against the law we're going to break it
all down let's take a listen big news of
the week Fox fired Tucker Carlson
um fox has gone left they've gone woke
we're clearly calling them out for
Tucker is a great voice for
conservatives across the country he
doesn't have the platform anymore will
you weigh in on Fox's decision to fire
probably one of the more conservative
voices most important voices in America
absolutely I think it was devastating to
our first amendment Eric I see it as a
very serious problem our first amendment
is Free Speech but it's also freedom of
press and when a gigantic Media company
like Fox News fires their number one uh
Tucker Carlson not for him doing
anything wrong uh not because his
ratings were bad but they literally
fired him because they came to the woke
mob now that's completely untrue
Tucker Carlson caused a
multi-hundred million if not
multi-billion dollar problem for Fox
News Fox News made this decision based
on money Not only was Tucker's program
partially responsible for the news
coverage that got them sued by dominion
and smartmatic and so far led to a
nearly 800 million dollar lawsuit uh
settlement uh rather in favor of
dominion he also is being sued by a
former staffer for alleged
discrimination and sexism and so on and
so forth behind the scenes he
potentially will have caused another
lawsuit by Ray Epps that may be
forthcoming it this was a financial
thing but that's not the focus of this
segment it's marjorie's misunderstanding
of the First Amendment what we're seeing
is we're seeing the end of the first
amendment that's how I see it I can't
see it any other way we've seen
censorship out of control we we saw the
federal government Department of
Homeland Security aligned with big Tech
to censor Americans uh for several years
now on political issues because they
weren't speaking the speech that was the
chosen speech to say well neither was
Tucker Carlson Tucker Carlson was
pushing the limit every single night on
his show and he was telling the news
stories that the American people wanted
to hear I also want to point out that
many Democrats even watch Tucker Carlson
okay sure so the question here is is
there any way in which a company firing
an employee could violate the First
Amendment the way Marjorie Taylor green
says the First Amendment of the
Constitution
to the Constitution protects
uh individuals
and in theory companies as well
from government actions that interfere
with freedom of speech religion press
assembly and petition private companies
private companies are not bound by the
first amendment in the same way and on
the other hand
um they also generally have the right to
set their own rules and policies this is
something that people like Marjorie
Taylor green on the right claim to
Revere as one of the highest goals and
and virtues of the United States legal
system
and this applies to employment as well
now could firings be illegal sure
there's all sorts of wrongful
termination that that Canon often is
argued by by employees uh if Tucker were
to be fired because he's white or
because he's Christian certainly he
would have a very good case for wrongful
termination uh I don't believe it would
have anything to do with the First
Amendment it would violate employer
non-discrimination law but the idea that
because they fired Tucker the first
amendment has been violated merely
because Tucker spoke on TV is ridiculous
it's ridiculous and it shouldn't even be
you know the sad thing is that we have
to explain it in this way now is there
any way is there any way where a company
could be violating the First Amendment
rights of an employee imagine that an
employee speaks out about a matter of
public concern as a citizen and their
speech isn't related to their job duties
in any way
you can try to argue that your first
amendment rights were violated it's very
tough to do if it's a government job
it's slightly easier to do but it's a
tough it's a tough uh standard to reach
some states have laws that protect
employees above and beyond the First
Amendment like for example some states
have laws that prohibit employers from
retaliating against employees for
political activity outside of work so
that would be a situation where there's
an additional protection and the
employee would be able to
um hold their employer to account do any
of these circumstances even remotely
apply to Fox News firing Tucker Carlson
not absolutely not absolutely not and so
we are faced once again with this
question do right-wingers not actually
know what the First Amendment does and
what it is or do they know but they
realize their followers don't
and so they blatantly lie to them on TV
I don't know you be the judge but what
we do know is Marjorie Taylor green is
humiliatingly wrong here